або так і на ту зі складу радіо ви його
не і наведення авакс регулярно
патрулює небо над польщею у вас на
пляма чий калінінград щодо даних
розбір то не з у приватних влаштований у тиму
російському анклаві ви ікла я з turbo
виніс темряву
а jetsam вже пуруші то баланс сил у
районі альянс хоче його щит і свій бій
здати є а лактоза c платить ними США
вимикає на оборону махаючий сочилися від
50 ярдів доларів забив не shushi
inci члени нато розум і зятем у 12 разів
більше не вимикаючи волоку британія і 16
разити більше нижньому еччі на для кулі
мене не ярусі я витру чаю по ночі та seat
мільярдів
а україна 4 c5 сотки ввп шкірну
україни у нас головних ви міг вашингтону
до брюсселя щоб шкіра нас край на ту
поспішала свою броню ви витратити до двох бо
сотки ввп вершись учасники в alliance
wpa катю гонору [ __ ] поважного чого
чиччо сша отже за всіх заплатити
справедливо розсудив фінансового
навантаження smc стала головною темою про
каже міністр оборони краю на ту
меседж заперечив фінансовий потяг ряду
вченим і ось уже добрих прийняв і я
вилітаю тупа нанести в тому що альянс
буду єдиним на жаль вирішення нинішніх проблем
ппп генсек нато йенс столтенберг хитрий
мій ви можуть США а про 2 адже сотки ввп
на оборону нам по три дно далі витрачаєте
на оборону та їх несправедливий раз
підняв це було б їм головним пріоритетом
клею вступивши на посаду у 2014 уроки
бага тих уроків з аварією витрат
я радою за видами це все тим же позаду
that we are the fallen ще у 2014 та роті
на саміті альянсу в Уельсі його
учасники думи волосся досі ти мід їх
2 адже сотки ввп проти розум 10 руки Аліна
затягування тіла процесу в дружини мої
годинник поважають експерти адміністрація
трампа робот акцент на внутрішню
політику вони на міжнародну означає
рахунків та акція була в астані руки та
десятиліття топ то я щур прикладом віра
купою афганістані
прогулювалася з США ми при трампі ни по
вашому
і тут кущ їм всі щурів білля кордоні в
Європі стоять і дали більше
навантаження на Європу заростаючи бюджет
ними чини на нинішній рік виглядають і так
міністерство по рації у 3 травня травня 140
миль я джек гру за крима значно сума
буде прямого на надбавкою до пенсії
вона потребує міноборони виділити 37
мільярдів бюджет не матчі на вище 4 рік
постіль без дефіцитні зі шкірним раком
зростає
чого не скажеш про інч україни на atoi
для цих заощаджень оборонному бюджету
можливо трохи але по значить вся на
соціальних витратах